you know independent films don't get
enough love guys example a the view
count that's gonna be on this reaction
this is a top rewards here video
requests from our homeboy our good
friend Jason Dolan
you have my number Jason but you sent me
a wonderful patreon message here
explaining why you're requesting this
video for this month here's the video
announcement for the Spirit Awards why
don't you watch this to react the
nominations which pick up where the
Oscars left off this will allow you to
talk about how many of these films
you've seen well this is gonna be an
embarrassing number I love to hear you
talk up the spirits which air the night
before the Oscars on IFC I watch it
every year a lot of the people miss out
of the Oscars and didn't miss here I
expect uncut gems in The Farewell to do
very well this year I always think it's
great when more people talk about the
spirits I know they will never be the
Oscars but it would be nice if people
talked about them as much as I talk
about the Golden Globes at least I'm
also friends with Powell Poage or Zell
ski ski yes that's pretty much what I
said who received the best director of
photography nomination he shot the short
film the Lord of Catan Catan Chris
Kattan in which I was a producer that
friend yeah yep cool that's so good to
know man people like friend pants and
amy acker they got buffy cred
I also want to take a moment to thank
the people who worked so hard to come up
with today's nominations
this year we had over 50 dedicated film
lovers and filmmakers serve on our
Spirit Award nominating committees they
watched and discussed over 500 films
fiction nonfiction international and
American in order to arrive at today's
nominations I'm especially appreciative
of the leadership provided by the chairs
of our nominating committees and most
especially to set you Rawal senior
manager of nominations without whom none
of this would happen and her entire team
so thank you thank you and now here to
announce our nominees are two incredibly
talented actors our first presenter can
be seen in Atlanta the Joker and
Deadpool - our second presenter 18
emmy-nominated actress executive
producer co-creator director and star of
Russian doll please help me welcome the
wonderful Channel good morning thanks
for being here so early
good morning with the filmmaker grant
categories each grant recognizes
emerging filmmakers who have not yet
received the recognition they deserve
winners of the filmmaker grants will be
announced at the 2020 Spirit Awards
nominee brunch on Saturday January 4th
our first grant today is the Boni award
sponsored by American Airlines this
grant is given to a mid-career female
director and honors the first female to
fly for a major US airline the award
includes a $50,000 unrestricted grant
and the finalists are Mary L Heller
Kelly Reichardt and Lulu Wong the truer
than fiction award is presented to an
emerging director of nonfiction features
this award includes a $25,000
unrestricted grant the finalists are
correct a la director of black mother
Davie Rothbart director 17 blocks nadia
Shahab director of ja Doland Eric Stoll
and chase Whiteside directors of America
I've seen all of them someone to watch
award honors a talented filmmaker of
singular vision who has not yet received
appropriate recognition and includes a
$25,000 unrestricted grant finalists are
Rashad Ernesto Green director of
premature ash Mayfair director of the
third wife and Joe Talbot director the
last black man in San Francisco I've
heard of that it's my biopic the
producers award which is given to an
emerging producer who despite highly
limited resources demonstrates the
creativity tenacity and vision required
to produce quality independent films the
award includes a $25,000 unrestricted
grant the finalists are Mali Asher
Krista Paris Ryan Zacharias I know all
those 2020 film Independent Spirit Award
nominees in the category of Best
Supporting female Jennifer Lopez
Hustler's Taylor Russell for recognizing
that's a supporting Xiao Xu Zhen the
farewell Lauren Lolo Spencer give me
liberty and Octavia Spencer loose loose
the nominees in the category of Best
Supporting male are Willem Dafoe the
lighthouse
yeah male a Jew honey boy Shia LeBeouf
honey boy Jonathan majors the last black
man San Francisco is lead air support
nominees in the cabinet the nominees in
the category Best Screenplay are Noah
Baumbach marriage story yes crazy
Jason beg you Sean Schneider to dust
Ronald Bronstein Benny safty Josh safty
uncut gems Chinoy a Chuku clemency
Tarell Alvin McCraney
high flying bird the nominees in the
category all these movies Federica
Bailey Stephan Bristol see you yesterday
Hanna boss Paul thorine driveways
Bridget savage Cole danielle crew d blow
the man down
Jocelyn de Boer Don lebay
or grass James Montague Craig W Sanger
the vast of night nominees in the
category of Best Cinematography are Todd
pan hazel hustlers Jaron Blaschke the
lighthouse Natasha brayer honey boy
Janine should run garage the third wife
midsummer it's some more finally a Julie
Bissau the third wife Ronnie Bronstein
Benny safdie uncut gems
Tyler L cook sort of trust Louise Ford
the lighthouse I could tell I'm coach
I'm gonna get the nominees in the best
category of international film Best
International Film our invisible life
Leamas Arab parasite portrait of a lady
on fire in a table row and the souvenir
parasite will not win
nominees documentary our American
Factory Apollo 11 forced amapola lenny
land island of the hungry ghosts the
nominees for the John Cassavetes award
are burning cane coal well give me
liberty premature and wild nights with
Emily wait there's more
the nominees the nominees in the
category of best female lead are Karen
Allen Colwell Hangchow driveways
Elizabeth moss her smell Mary Kay place
Diane alfre woodard clemency Renee
Zellweger Judy that heard of Judy thank
God I heard of one of them the best
category of best male lead mr Chris
calloused give me liberty Kelvin
Harrison jr. loose give me liberty
Pattinson in the lighthouse Adam Sandler
uncut gems and mighty eschew nuts the
Mustang almost the nominees in the
category of Best first feature our book
smart the climb books one finally got
some love somewhere I'm in San Francisco
the Mustang see you yesterday
two more cards we are given to one
film's director casting director and
ensemble cast and it's for a marriage
story director Noah Baumbach casting
directors Douglas Abel and Francine Mae
slur ensemble cast members are Alan Alda
Laura Dern Adam driver Julie Hagerty
Scarlett Johansson Ray Liotta Ozzy
Robertson and Merritt Wever the nominees
in the category of best feature are a
hidden life clemency the farewell
marriage story uncut gems we look
forward to seeing you again on February
at the beach in Santa Monica join us
congratulations to all those films
getting the recognition they deserve
I've seen two or three of them yes
likewise I've heard of five or six I've
seen the lighthouse oh good I've seen
marriage stir a hustler and hustlers all
three movies that were promoted in a way
that you probably weren't even a hundred
percent sure if they were independent
films or not you know they got that 8:24
push for some of those yeah so I don't
feel qualified to really speak on who I
think should win or boy I think
shouldn't win I think Jason's friend
should win for cinematography in
mid-summer
oh is that what his friend did yeah Wow
NIT Samar was the best movie I have not
seen all year I like that movie yeah I
need to watch it I've seen hereditary
twice though does that count
yeah I'm think it's basically well I'm a
big fan of both natasha Lyonne and
Tsotsi bates that's a take away
got really Jason Dolan pledges to our
patreon he's trying to embarrass us now
the trouble with that tear gotta go
watch qualified really now we gotta go
what was that one that kept getting its
name repeated that was probably pretty
great we gotta go watch that now I want
to watch island of the goat ghosts The
Hungry Ghost that was called yes yeah
that sounds cool the island of The
Hungry Ghost
too for the money call me Liberty give
me liberty give me liberty the last
black man in Sam please San Francisco
sandy sandy Cisco is the last black man
in San Dimas this is a video for you
Jason we're just trying to remember some
of these titles that marriages story
that's a big independent movie if this
were the Oscars would be very obvious
which ones are gonna win it's very good
Adam Sandler I feel like the uncut gems
has to win something by default at this
awards I have the impression uncut gems
will win for best editing because that
is one of the most talked about things I
hear about that movie in every category
for the movie I've seen I could like
totally riff on how great of a
performance or execution in that
category it is until I die I haven't
really I mean like I've done a review
for the lighthouse have you seen that
yet no gosh Jon tell yourself the horror
fan I've heard it's not really that much
of a horror movie
it is totally is okay jump scares go
sorry I want to be on during my my
country yeah those are my favorite
horror movies I can say that for the
insomnia ward for marriage story as a
film in this I've only watched marriage
story as of yesterday I was surprised
because that you know I everything you
hear about is Adam driver and Scarlett
Johansson really acting their ass off
don't sneeze I didn't can't prove it
there's so much acting in that movie
from them a lot of Acts I would describe
it a lot of acting but I was pleasantly
surprised by the rest of the cast in
that film - Ray Liotta was great in the
film and I wasn't even aware he was in
it so I'm like oh damn oh that's raised
here
and laura dern all the prey she's
getting yeah she's incredible in the
movie Alan all those really good in the
film the little kid is really good too
that's a wonderful ensemble cast
parasite is too though they just want an
ensemble cast it at the SAG Awards or
something yeah yeah this is great
content us just vaguely remembering this
video and then recapping this Tasha
leone and za z beets are two wildly
opposing figures to put home to each
other but they're both from two of my
favorite recent TV shows so for me this
is perfect yeah it looked like they were
ready to get off that stage about
halfway through it that was the best
part of it yeah they're like what I
didn't realize I'm reading this much
reading all of the nominees and half
these cards have the same like there's a
grant and it's unlimited and then then
you know a few other pieces of info and
then the nominee how do we get a grant
we got to make a really great
independent film
oh god it's too much work I know I just
react to an independent film yeah thanks
for that let's do a portrait of a lady
on fire watch along that's a terrific
movie if there's anything I've got them
from this video especially I was talking
about it is that we are part of the
problem we are we didn't fare well
we didn't watch so many of these other
independent films is the market is
packed guys it's hard to keep up with
all the TV shows and all the movies and
then we do it's like we ought to usually
keep up with what's popular room up you
know what's really trending right now
and usually these independent films are
not part of it but maybe if we lived up
to our influence or title we can swayed
more audiences to check out more of
these unseen gems ooh I see what you did
there yeah that's nice to see as a
reference sneaky no I did like a Russian
doll of a joke because it you know as a
joke inside the raw videos this is the
best video of the month okay great way
to kick off Jason you're really excited
yeah
Jason is so fulfilled by our independent
film credibility guy I think Robert
Redford directed the Mustang well which
one of these independent films should we
watch right away right now I'm getting
my way through all the oscar films that
I feel like I must watch like all the
best picture films oh man I'm getting ya
watching over as many times possible
and I am also catching up on the best
actor and actress category so I want to
get like the main ones done and then
maybe I'll move on to uncut gems I will
the farewell those are the two those out
of the independent films they kept
talking about those are the two of them
like I must see those uncut gems
actually on Amazon
is it yeah I think you have to pay like
three dollars to rent it or whatever but
uh ah I hate supporting independent
films with money but there should be
more originality yeah I don't like
paying for these highly expensive
productions but could you do more
original ones please I think we've
earned insane subscribers like that
notification hit the like button cuz you
think you know you like this video
Jason Jason as I can't talk about it so
I won't we're gonna spend the whole
video not talking about it he he is
booked something pretty amazing recently
doing a screenwriter he's landed a great
gig and I'm supposed to keep it on the
down low let's just say Captain Marvel -
he's gonna have an interesting take I
can't tell but congratulations Jason and
sincerely thank you for attempting to
help us branch out and expand her
horizons and for the constant support
you show us buddy thank you for this
homework assignment
you